telogen is an interesting concept it's
very controversial in fact if you one of
the things that continually happens over
and over again in psychology is that
psychologists discover all sorts of new
kinds of intelligence and you know the
biggest to proponents of that sort of
thing I suppose with Bob Sternberg who
came up with this thingy called
practical intelligence and then Howard
Gardner who came up with the theory of
multiple intelligences which had a very
large effect on educational psychology
when the theory was first proposed and
that's not saying much because generally
speaking it's very difficult to find a
discipline that's more susceptible to
fads in educational psychology and as
far as I can tell generally speaking
each fad is worse than the previous one
so you know Gardner posited that I think
there were seven oh there they are seven
or eight different intelligences
linguistic musical logical mathematical
spatial body kinesthetic intrapersonal
and interpersonal and people talk about
emotional intelligence and they talk
about practical intelligence and as far
as I'm concerned all about complete
rubbish and there are technical reasons
for that I mean there's technical and
philosophical reasons for that the first
thing is you can't just mess up a word
you know the whole point of having a
word is so that it defines something
that describes something and doesn't
describe other things right and so you
can you can make the word intelligence
account for whatever you want so you can
say that the ability advanced is a form
of intelligence but the problem with
that is you blur out the word so badly
you can't tell what it means anymore and
so and I would also point out we had
perfectly good words for those major
intelligences we call them talents and
so it's perfectly reasonable to make a
distinction between the talent and
intelligence now you might say well how
the hell do you know the difference like
if things look similar to some degree
then how do you know if they're the same
or different well that's exactly what
you do when you do the construct
validity process so let's
you raided a number of people on their
dancing abilities and then you rated the
number of people on their ability to
multiply two digits two two-digit
numbers in their heads and quickly well
then you see technically if both of
those were intelligences then the people
who could dance better could multiply
two-digit numbers faster in their head
and that they would be slightly
positively sorry see that's what happens
when I don't have any diet coke so
anyway if intelligence was the right
word to subsume both of those then what
you see is there would be a high
correlation the people who were good
dancers would also be the ones who could
multiply most rapidly and I mean
multiply in their head but that's but
you're not going to be able to extract
out a single factor like that it's just
not it's just not the case that those
things associate like that so for
something to be one phenomena the things
that it obviously I've talked too much
different master all the things that are
subsumed under that definition have to
be correlated and highly correlated
because otherwise they're not the same
thing it's the definition of the same
thing now IQ is a very peculiar
construct a very unique construct from a
psychological perspective but also these
more generally from a social science
perspective because IQ has the most
predictive validity of anything ever
discovered in the social sciences period